[Musique]
bonsoir les ploues les ploucs
tout le monde surtout que j'avais fait
l'effort quand même d'être dans le thème
ce coup-là donc je me suis dit le repas
va être long ce soir il est pas là pour
rigoler j'ai réussi adapté au standing
de notre hôte ce soir merci beaucoup
pour les forts tu es tout en tout en
beauté tout en classe comme à ton avis
tout de suite
tu es toute nu en dessous oui mais
c'est quelque chose tu peux t'asseoir
avec cette robe parce que le trou il est
juste là mais si j'ai l'habitude
[Musique]
ça va
làoise a dû laisser à la sécurité son
bob multicolore considéré comme un
symbole LGBT
avant le même match ce journaliste
américain s'est vu reprocher également
de porter un signe politique avec son
t-shirt mais lui a pu garder son
vêtement après 25 minutes de négociation
serrée
la liberté c'est devant les écrans
géants des Fan Zone là où la bière a 15
euros la pinte coule à flot les donneurs
de leçons
occidentaux mais européen qui sont là à
dire un maintenant si vous comprenez ne
respecte pas nos valeurs le droit des
femmes c'est pas grave par le droit des
homosexuels c'est pas grave c'est pas
grave
donc vous faites vraiment une émission
en direct depuis tout à l'heure
vous êtes au courant que les Bleus leur
premier match de Coupe du Monde la
concrètement fait une émission regardez
par quatre personnes et demi
on est très peu mais c'est non vraiment
il y a pas de souci chapeau maillot et
drapeau aux couleurs de la France David
et ce que l'on appelle un fan leader et
là pour représenter les fans français il
participe à sa quatrième Coupe du monde
mais celle-ci est différente puisque son
billet d'avion aller-retour et son
hébergement ont été payés par le comité
suprême du Qatar on vient pas parce
qu'on est invité c'est un plus
évidemment très appréciable on nous
offre des choses qu'on aurait voulu
faire qu'on aille soit prévu de faire
par nous-mêmes ou qu'on rêverait de
faire football
et le patron c'est lui mon nom est Toufi
je suis le président depuis 8 ans
le foot c'est comme la marmite chez
Astérix on tombe dedans tout petit ou
alors le foot restera pour toujours une
énigme ce soir France Australie je
regarderai sans Platini sans Idan sans
Benzema allez les bleus 300 personnes de
notre organisation est actuellement ici
au Qatar
s'il vous plaît comprenez notre émotion
c'est une humble requête arrêtez de
partager des fausses infos
avez-vous été payé par le Qatar
Penny de qui que ce soit au Qatar ou de
la FIFA
moi je vais je vais mettre les pieds
dans le plat c'est pas la Coupe du Monde
2022 au Qatar qui fait chier c'est que
ça soit une coupe du monde dans un pays
musulman qui a du pognon qui fait chier
je vais te le dire c'est juste ça
docteur c'est juste que c'est un pays
qui accueille qui a les moyens
d'accueillir un événement
interplanétaire comme la Coupe du monde
que c'est le premier pays et il faut le
dire c'est aussi musulman qui abrite une
coupe du monde d'accord
elle dit Dieu viens là à ce moment-là
c'est incroyable c'est le monde qui qui
en fait parce que là on entend Allah et
on est heureux il y a plus aucune
ambiguïté c'est magique c'est ça le foot
20% des Français disent préfèrent
regarder le match plutôt que de faire
l'amour c'est le genre de sondage quel
on échappe pas alors de chaque grande
compétition menée auprès de personnes
dans une dizaine de pays pour tout vous
dire je les reçois directement
maintenant et des indices et donc côté
français en effet insupporter sur cinq à
vos préférés les exploits de Giroud à
une partie de jambes en l'air je sais
bien sûr on peut tous permettre c'est
aujourd'hui non vraiment je peux faire
la chronique à poil ça choquera personne
allez foutu pour foutu
oui je sais Patrick ça laisse rêveur
c'est pas le produit d'appel de l'année
mais on fait ce qu'on peut à la une de
ce 22 novembre c'était hier et
heureusement
1/10 explique qu'il ferait l'amour plus
rapidement si leur équipe favorite joue
c'est à dire rapidement à la mi-temps ou
même pendant paisible non mais voilà
bref c'est une belle saison de
romantisme qui s'ouvre et c'est pas fini
un quart des participants déclare qu'il
penserait au foot pendant leur partie de
jambes en l'air un tiers admet avoir
déjà menti à sa moitié pour pouvoir
regarder un match tranquillement et
surtout 45% admettent qu'une victoire de
leur équipe boosterait leur libido
[Musique]
tu n'es pas une gaufre
quel showman vous entrez vous checkez
tout le monde machin ça c'est quand même
incroyable
ta mère le covid là
[Applaudissements]